yeah welcome to this video playing well
mustard loogie from yeah from where he's
got the Italian flag he is originally I
think from Russia but then lift in the
United States for very long time even
being the United States Champion I think
and yeah maybe is playing in Italy I
don't know or is some business ventures
there okay the Queens gambit accepted i
play this down dc5 line simply because i
don't know any sharp one hmm interesting
we are castling is some it's not very
common actually and this in this line
okay but i don't want to pretend that I
I have a deep knowledge about this this
opening I don't I only know a couple of
ideas one idea is that white wants to
play Knight c4 and um and play against
the the pole on b6 however here if I
take I don't have a good discovery here
should I go they don't know but ok I can
also take and play f3 f3 Andy for this
is 11 idea efore as designed to design
to to make this bishop on b7 am stupid
looking piece
you should be fun
what if we affect xe3 rock d 7 he's got
two pieces hanging
yeah this is a good move what why is
this playable ah well because I didn't
see that move it still looks fishy for
black doesn't it
I didn't see it though so where'd you go
look you one probably it's very active
this guy's playing everything instantly
and I him I don't know i think it's just
bad 5 y ye 530 rook f7 know ok so we his
his very relaxed about getting his
bishop out of play and giving me two
rooks here on the seventh-ranked maybe
it's no big deal but i don't know
ok
a night the night I would be able to
play Knight a5 c6 something like that it
would be excellent I need to get out of
them out of the checks here
yeah he's just playing everything
instantly but good or bad I don't know I
don't know if this was necessary but ok
I think it gives me some additional
ideas but i don't i don't know a six
hangs at the moment so I've got h4 h5 in
addition night be 726 as well
926 st idea so g phi f is this a move g5
and g6 I can also just take the poem and
let's let's take this bond make sure
that it's not queening easily okay and
back to this active post
yeah can barely move
yeah it's still relatively solid I mean
it looks terrible but a bit how do you
actually win maybe just okay seven and
take the pawn
yeah just drew k 7 I don't really rabbi
okay he needs to move first I don't I
don't see it was something great after
all them I can I can also just take f7
huh probably with the bishop yeah with
the bishop of course he has a hard time
to prevent that
f6 looks terrible after night f5
yeah now is down on the clock well maybe
this is the dick disconnection I cannot
ping him it has a bit out of character
to spend so much time I hope I'm not
disconnected as well no I'm not so maybe
lost connection but i think the position
is really terrible allow forfeit due to
disconnection yeah yeah I don't know if
it was some if he did this out of
frustration or just a technical issue I
don't know I'm not sure blackest black
is in very bad shape but maybe you can
can try to defend it somehow the
computer us and play rock the edge which
are also considered I mean at least
getting getting rid of pieces k only
problem as if you look at something like
that I mean the king is just completely
out of the game and cannot easily be
activated because of the strong bishop
and he's got a number of weaknesses
those in particular while my pawns are
protected of course the five point can
be protected by the bishop but the a
porn is really weak I don't know it
looks very difficult to defend um yeah
somehow this was supposed to be and I of
course I had overlooked bishops he ate
but it is it is compensation I mean I
control those two lines and this was
just yeah I don't know I mean this guy
is a good Grandmaster for some reason
but if I've just is just a Geralyn if in
my book why would you allow me to
dominate with Bishop c4 and stuff why
not Bishop f6 for example intending
Bishop d8 kicking the the rook out and
this now I don't know it's just it's
just very good compensation also this
everything instantly was just this is
just an offside piece and now I'm
I have very active I mean this is at
least good compensation I think why does
inverter here it's it's difficult to
realize I mean the one problem is that
that if you hear I cannot do that
because of this Bishop detail I mean not
a huge problem or anything but it's not
not the positive move not helping me
much so I tried that and then this still
keeping the the bishop out of play I
don't know and what does help me this
age 5 business I mean I'm just I'm just
gaining space and and having a great
position yeah here just take it the
anti-black I mean we had this is the
final position way des connected this
really not a lot of move I mean f6 is is
a move but what now it just collapses
okay thanks for watching